So when we last left
off, we had successfully
learned how to unlock
achievements and increment
achievements by
a certain amount.
And this is great.
This is progress.
But you may have
noticed that I did this
by embedding these achievement
ID strings directly
into the code.
And for a lot of
you, this probably
makes you wince and you were
like what are you doing?
You're l embedding strings
directly into the code.
This is terrible style.
And you should be
ashamed of yourself.
And I am.
So I'm just going to take
a few moments to fix this
before we go ahead and implement
the remaining two achievements.
Now probably as
a game developer,
you're going to do
something even more
sophisticated than
what I'm doing.
You're probably going to save
all these IDs in a properties
file somewhere you
can easily read in.
In my case, I'm just going to
do this by creating an e-note.
So let me go over to my GM
and achieving manager here.
And let's create
a little e-note.
So I'm going to use our
type def and NS_ENUM
macro that Apple
has provided for us.
It'll be an NS integer.
And its name-- we'll call
it GMN Achievement ID.
And this will be
defined as-- I guess
I will enter these
achievements in the same way
that they are entered
in the Play console.
So we're going to say
Achievement ID Lucky Guess.
And we'll make
sure this is zero.
Then we can add Achievement ID.
Send to Guesser.
Achievement ID First Time,
and Achievement ID OtnayOotay.
There we go.
And now we can go ahead and
change these method signatures
so that instead of
passing in it in a string,
we're actually going to pass
in our GMN Achievement ID ENUM.
So I'm going to change this
here from NS String to GMN
Achievement ID.
And I'm going to
the same thing here.
And then in our .m file, we can
go through the work to actually
translate these
into real strings.
So, again, you
might be doing this
by looking at some kind
of file in the device.
But for me, I'm just going to go
ahead and create a simple array
here.
So we're going to declare
Static, NSString, Const,
Achievement IDs.
And I guess I can go ahead and
a copy and paste these directly
from our Developer console.
Let's look it up here.
Here we go-- Guess My Number.
And Achievements--
all right, cool.
We can just copy
over this first one.
And, yes, this is
kind of a pain.
But we only have
to do this once.
And there we go.
We now have a range of
Achievement ID strings.
Where each one of
these strings is
placed in this
array in a way that
corresponds to their ENUM value.
So looking up an actual
Achievement ID string
from the ENUM should
be pretty easy.
So now we can finally
update our methods.
So I'm going to change
this from NS String
to GMN Achievement ID.
And then we will say our NS
String Achievement ID as String
equals Achievement IDs.
OK, that's a lot
of Achievement IDs.
Sorry for not
naming these better.
But now that we
have this thing, I
can now just copy paste
it in here and we're done.
And you know what?
We can just do the
same thing down here
in our Increment Method.
Pop that in.
This is now a GMN
Achievement ID.
And we can put that in here.
Whoops.
Actually, before I
go on, I realized
I need to go into my game model.
And, yeah, we've
got some errors now.
Let's go ahead and replace this
call with our Achievement ID.
First time.
And then we can similarly
replace this one
with Achievement
ID Centiguesser.
And, by the way,
gosh isn't it nice
now that we have this auto
completion for us that
lets us know exactly
what Achievement we want
to be adding here.
Anybody that's
reviewing this code
can immediately figure out
what Achievement I meant
to increment just by looking at
this very logically named ENUM
instead of completely
opaque string
that has no other context.
So I like this a
whole lot better.
It makes the code cleaner.
And makes it easier to read.
And we got Auto Complete.
Hooray.
All right, so now
let's run this thing.
We see that we're
still getting errors.
And this is actually because
in between the last two
recordings, I upgraded my
G+ Library from 1.4 to 1.5.
And it turns out it now
wants this other framework
to access the Address Book.
I'll show you why it needs
that in a later lesson.
But let's go back here.
Go into our Frameworks.
And let's add Address Book.
Build this.
All right.
Everything's good.
Let's try this again.
All right, see we're back.
I can check out my Achievements.
Everything seems to be working.
Let's go ahead and
implement these last two.
So I'm going to stop this.
We're going to go
back to my Game Model.
And I think these last two are
actually pretty straightforward
here.
Let's add the Otnay
Ootay Ipray one.
We can do that right here.
Basically what I can do
is I can look at the guess
and say if the
guess is either less
than the Player
Min, what we know
is the minimum logical value
for the player or our guess,
is greater than our player max.
Then that was not really
a very good guess.
We could do
self.achievementManager.
Unlock Achievement with ID.
Achievement ID Otnay Ootay.
Love that Auto Complete.
And our Lucky Guess Achievement
is also pretty easy to add.
Right here in this section where
we discover that we've won,
we can just look at
the number of guesses
and if it's equal to
one then we can say,
hey self.achievementManager,
let's unlock
that Achievement with the ID.
Achievement ID Lucky yes.
And now we can go
ahead and test these.
Now I am not going to test
the Lucky Guesser Achievement.
We would be here a very
long time if I did.
Or I guess maybe I could cheat.
But there we go.
There's our Achievements.
Looks like we still have
our First Timer one.
Don't have our Lucky Guess one.
Let me play Easy Mode here.
And I'm going to say--
I'm going to guess 50.
And it's saying
it's lower than 50.
Hmm.
Well, what if I
were to guess 60?
Well that's not a
very good guess there.
But I have seen now that
the Achievement lot Unlocked
banner appears.
And if I were to go back
and look at my Achievements,
it now shows up there in
my list of Achievements
that I've earned.
So that's pretty good.
One issue you might
be noticing, though,
is that it's hard to test
these more than once.
Right?
At some point you're probably
going to have a Test Plan.
And one of those things that
your testers should be doing--
if they're not, they
should be doing this--
is to make sure that you can
earn all these Achievements.
And you don't want to be
creating new test accounts
every time you want to test
a new set of Achievements.
So I think it's important to,
at least for testing purposes,
to figure out how to
reset your Achievements.
And we can look at doing
that in the next lesson.